all right so just remember again it's
step by step you go through each of
these features and then you put them
appropriately onto there okay so here's
the last example we're going to work
through together and then I'm going to
set you the rest of the questions in the
exercise look carefully and have a think
about the effect of the transformations
you can see here okay just like before
I'm gonna rearrange a teeny bit pop that
minus sign over in the left hand side
where it belongs tough multiplied both
sides by negative one that tells me over
there immediately on the left hand side
this thing is going to be upside down
right there's gonna be a vertical
reflection happening okay so that's the
first thing I know then I say log base
two so you'll get to see all different
kinds of bases here and obviously that
makes a difference to the scale so be
cautious there and then I've got my X
plus four so that plus four means
there's going to be a horizontal
translation and it's going to go 4 units
to the left okay so I've got my general
shape in mind instead of being something
like this I'm gonna have the upside down
version so it's gonna look like this but
then of course I'm going to do that
translation over to the left and I hope
you can see once this guy is in the
right spot I'm going to get to intercept
as well and once I've done the
translation okay so let's start to get
all the pieces together let's work out
the intercepts when x equals 0 Y is
going to be negative log base 2 0 plus 4
so negative still out there on the front
log base 2 4 what is the number that
when you raise 2 to that number to that
power you get 4 well that's 2 squared 2
squared gives you 4 so therefore that
log is equal to 2 so I've got away
intercept that's great and I'm
anticipating that I will get an x
intercept as well from my rough look at
the graphs shape so I'll go y equals 0
that means that I'll get 0 equals
negative log base 2 of X plus 4 that
minus sign I multiply both sides by
negative 1 so you just get log base 2 of
X plus 4 equals 0 and now I'm
going to do the reverse of what I did
earlier on in the lesson I'm going to
take this log equation and rewrite it as
an exponential write so that tells me
that x + 4 will be equal to 2 to the
power 0 so now I'm going to get x equals
subtract 4 from both sides 1 take away 4
is negative 3 and if I just think about
my intuition am i well that makes sense
because I thought I was moving 4 units
to the left so unsurprisingly my x
intercept has gone into the negatives
okay cause it's moved that far asymptote
needs to be there as well the asymptote
is normally at x equals 0 but I've moved
it 4 units to the left so therefore it's
at x equals negative 4 do I need a point
for scale no I don't because I have two
intercepts so I've got two the
information that I need let's put this
thing together I need more space haven't
given myself enough working room
actually we'll just do it like this I'll
just cut this out of the way and we'll
bring it back in afterwards when you're
ready for that part of the exercise so
let's draw myself up I said axes here
and you're welcome to follow along maybe
you're ahead of me actually let's put
that guy in there and then horizontal
one like so ok now let's have a look at
all of the information that I pasted
together I've got X intercepts I've got
y intercepts and I also have an
asymptote so I've got x equals 0 y
equals negative 2 so therefore let's
let's put this guy underneath the axis
there at negative true that looks like
it's going to be an okay spot for me yep
fine I'm going to get my x intercept and
also my vertical asymptotes they're
going to kind of come in place next to
each other so they're both at negative
values so I'm going to go negative 1
negative 2 negative 3 negative 4 so
negative 4 that's where I'm gonna line
up my asymptotes like so please remember
always to label it x equals negative 4
and then x equals negative 3 that's
going to be my intercept right there
okay so you can kind of see now from the
very rough and dirty sketch that I did
up here look at my my overall shape you
can see as it bends downward as it
curves downward it's
meet the two spots on my corner axes
that I was hoping for so now maybe you
need to reposition your paper to get it
your hand in the right spot to do the
curve as best as you can but now I want
to try and thread the needle through
these different things so whoops that
was a terrible first trial give that
another girl mm-hmm I'm okay with that
yeah I'm satisfied with that we could
actually make it a little bit better on
the end here kind of bends a little bit
in a direction I didn't really want to
so let's make it go a little further and
flatter yeah I'm happy with that it
approaches the acetone and it gets
shallower and shallower but it does it's
in the negative direction have a look
have I got all the piece of information
that I want intercepts are there which
give me scale asymptotes there let's
label this guy negative log base 2 X
plus 4 and I think I'm pretty satisfied
with that